okay now one last thing you can just
keep on working on your bookmark if you
want to that's fine however the question
of battery now Daniel asked me to do and
a lot of you just too bloody just
skipped it so it's the same question
it's still question 5 but it's part of
its part 6 it's part 6 so it says it
starts off the same way on execute cos x
equals the third and then it says find
tangent of X onto so if you want to pay
attention to it then go ahead if not
that's fine okay now I the question the
first part is right I think part 1 just
just find it anywhere you like right so
the easiest way is work out what
businesses interested in the prius and
work out what this is and then you just
divide ok which i think for what was it
was like we rich well whatever they
let's see there's like more autumn
really free / this is taruna 4213 yeah
okay that's right so this is root 3 this
is repletion i cancel
and you just end up with 102 okay but
then they're like find it find it
without using those results which is
kind of like why they're doing that so
I'll show you there are two ways to do
it is it easy way it was a hard way but
the easy way I think I'm interesting
before it requires an identity that it's
not really my part of syllabus it's not
that hard to show but it's kind of like
if you don't know it you're like how to
paddle was I supposed to come up with
that okay so let's talk about this
consider the square root of now I'm
trying to get I try and get the tans in
terms of causative right and it's also
like it's it's double angle for cars
right now cause is useful because when
you think about double angle for cards
right I can rewrite it in terms of sine
squared or in terms of cos squared which
is really useful because that means i
can divide science by positive and then
I'm get it right so how exactly do i do
it think about this ok I think that's
sorry yeah ok now if I just do an
expansion here right remembering that I
have choice I've got three ways that I
can explain close to X but I want the
one that leads me to tears right so I
want all the signs at the top and all
the causes now the bottom ok so what's
going to happen the square root of 1
minus now what's the expansion's on its
own yeah what about us it's your side
1-2 use science for it ok the obvious
leopard use the same boat here but it's
not going to be useful to me right so
i'm going to write that as one of us
sorry
and now I used the cushion fault yeah so
this is 2 cos squared 1 ok so you can
see what cancels right you've got a
double negative here and there's two
ones so you're going to get 2 sine
squared on to chi squared so cancel
cancel square root of tan squared so
that's just 10 okay so how do I use that
in this case well what I want is 10 of X
or two so i'm going to divide every
angle here by two right that's going to
land upon 1 minus cos one paw spa right
which I already do so that's what I 1
minus a third that one plus a third so
that's the square root of two thirds on
before birds just wear it off a half
which is one on route you just like we
got before ok but like I said yeah I
only know what I've seen it a million
times so how else could you do it
remembering that there's going to be
some double angle business right let's
just think about 10 how'd I do any Ted
2x ok now actually i'll make a fetus or
confuse this now the just standard
attention for this is to tan theta on
1-10 square yes but what I want is X on
tues and Exodus right so i can like this
tan x equals 2 10 x on to 1-10 squared
okay so i'm trying to get this i'm
trying to tan x into the subject and
this is what I've got to work with ok
how do I turn this into this what's the
closest connection in terms of
identities between 10 and cars and
answer is probably sec squared right now
it's sick squared not sick so I have to
square things which is slightly awkward
but it's still going to work so i'm
going to write um Ted how many wonders
if I if I squat now i'm just going to
write obviously if I square both sides
thanks i'm going to get this
okay now i can rewrite this as what 1-6
squared now here I'm really really sick
of writing this minus one written yeah
okay good I'm gonna get really sick of
writing tenets into so I'm just going to
use the T results like as a name because
it stated so I've got to tea on 100
minus t squared squared now hold on a
second I've sort of got enough here
right in some senses oh where do I want
this square to be well I want to make
tea the subject right i solve for T so
i'm probably going to take the square
root over the other side now that i can
do that i can write this rather than
same plus or minus y think same is the
question before why can't I even want
anything about it just good sorry
because there's a tent ah good yes since
X is accused more importantly 10x is
therefore positive because you're not
hard to it just it just climbs right so
that's why anyway so you get the idea
now sec square so i'm going to take
cause turn upside down and square root
so that's going to be 8-1 sorry 9-1
preciate ya and i got this so i have a
route 84 there
now what would you do at this point
multiply whatever they are close to your
mobile minus T Square yep so I'm going
to go 8-8 T squared is equal sweetie now
what and divide through by two so let's
see this is actually 2 root 2 is it a 2
root 2 minus 3t squared T so let's
divide through that gives me this for 2
minus root 2 T Square I suppose we might
as well I wanted ah I suppose I might as
well bring this guy of the other side so
minus T equals 0 now yeah it totally is
actually we've already done what we
needed to namely this substitution T was
that to show that it is a quadratic ok
now looks awkward but stay with it sorry
Lenny runs all the way done in order to
make this just a little bit easier for
you to solve obviously it doesn't
factorize nicely ok so I'm going to use
the quadratic formula a quadratic
formulas like this rate minus B on to a
ok now I have all these irrational
numbers here right now I can't get rid
of all of them but I can choose where
they're going to be right since my right
hand side 0 i can multiply through by
whatever constant I like yes so Bible
looks about how i'm going to multiply
everything throu through x minus root 2
that is
it's all right it's a little bit yeah
okay good now the reason why it's like I
haven't got any rid of any irrational
numbers right but the Russian number is
better there than there because see how
I'm going to square that irrational
number so it'll be a little bit better
ok I can remove but as soon as we get so
minus B which is minus root 2 plus or
minus now note that right I'm expecting
only one answer at the end not to might
be an extension of quadratic so if your
watchful for when I can get rid of that
anyway what's underneath the square root
b square which is two minus 4ac for a
scene that's going to be aged 88 size 16
minus 2a which is for ya okay so I've
got my industry to plus or minus now
that's that's right 18 which is actually
three root 2 a 3 root so now I've got
two solutions right the first one is
minus for group 2 14 and the other one
is to route to write but weird i have it
10x onto which is what this thing is
equal to right has to be positive
because of the domain restriction that
we've already been given so that's why I
kept disregard this airtight so now when
we got here this is root 2 or two
to be okay so clearly clearly this is a
superior method for solving it but its
superior on condition that you know this
identity right where is this it's
awkward but you didn't need to know any
extra stuff you just need to stay with
it so that's the two ways of approaching